comm check we're live target acquired  how was that  abort Ethan what happened in the Kremlin  it was a setup  Russians are classifying this as an  undeclared act of war the blame points  to you and your team president has  initiated ghost Protocol the entire IMF  has been disavowed so what happens now  your mission should you choose to  the secretary is dead four of us are all  that remains from the IMF no safe house  no support or extraction everyone  connected with this man it's an asset  with valuable information we come back  with our target or we don't come back  and how do you propose that we do that  we take them out yeah take your that but  you know discreetly it's greatly  this operation is over 42 begins  you can't explain yourself Brant who are  you really  we all have our secrets don't we eat  them  okay this is the slight wrinkle we're  gonna have to go into the server room  from the outside we I'm on the computer  you